moi j'adore Beyoncé mais la prochaine
fois il faudra prendre un producteur qui
vérifiera que le stade est disponible à
la bonne date faut quand même aussi
rappeler qu'il y a une autre mécontente
dans l'histoire c'est Aya Nakamura
[Musique]
à bientôt 50 ans Leonardo DiCaprio
multiplie les conquêtes féminines et la
superstar un petit penchant bien connu
pour les femmes plus jeunes que lui
dernière rumeur en date l'acteur serait
en couple avec une mannequin
franco-israélienne de 29 ans saccadet
avec qui il a été photographié lors
d'une soirée privée à Los Angeles
cette relation entre DiCaprio et cette
jeune fille de 19 ans a créé la
polémique outre-Atlantique et la star de
Titanic s'est fait lyncher sur les
réseaux sociaux en se faisant traiter de
pervers quelqu'un peut m'expliquer ce
qu'un homme de presque 50 ans en commun
avec une femme proche de la vingtaine
elle a le même âge que ma fille ma fille
va fêter son XIXe anniversaire dans 15
jours ça me répugne ça me dégoûte parce
qu'à chaque fois qu'elles atteignent 25
ans il les jarte alors je ne sais pas si
vous entendez par là des contrats tout
le monde y trouve son compte c'est juste
dégueulasse c'est un prédateur sexuel un
vieux dégueulasse de 50 ans
tu te rends compte quand même qu'aux
Etats-Unis elle n'est même pas majeure
si elle a dû avoir ses règles il y a 3
ans
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bordel
franchement tu as de la chance comme dit
Mathieu qui soit américain parce que là
c'est prédateur sexuel c'est Francisco
mais cetera c'est pas Léonardo Caprio
voilà c'est cool ça ne gentleman
agrément tu peux dire qu'elle serait un
peu vénale qu'elle veut se faire sa pub
etc ils sont chacun d'accord sur les
termes du deal comme elle dit Benoît et
cetera
accusé d'être responsable de l'absence
d'une seconde date pour le concert de
Beyoncé au Stade de France en raison de
travaux sur le RER bégresse a
contre-attaqué mercredi en mettant en
cause la société de production du
spectacle pour dire c'est pas à cause de
de nous alors elle a fait un petit une
petite vidéo en chantant très très drôle
j'ai reçu de nombreux messages de fans
de Beyoncé extrêmement déçu par
l'annulation de sa deuxième date de
concert à Paris alors il paraît que
c'est de ma faute je vais rectifier les
choses et le dire clairement je n'y suis
rigoureusement pour rien j'ai le dollar
mais faut pas charrier alors je le dis
moi j'adore Beyoncé je lui dis bienvenue
en Île-de-France mais la prochaine fois
il faudra prendre un producteur qui
vérifiera que le stade est disponible à
la bonne date bah là entièrement raison
ça fait deux ans qu'on sait que le Stade
de France n'est pas disponible à cette
date et l'autre idiot de producteur il
dit à Beyoncé tu viendras tel jour alors
qu'il est pas dispo excuse-moi il y a ça
m'a privé 80 000 personnes
de la deuxième concert et ça se réjouir
des millions de Parisiens ils prennent
leur horaires qui vont pouvoir le plus
vite faut quand même aussi rappeler
qu'il y a une autre mécontente dans
l'histoire c'est Aya Nakamura qui a son
concert en même temps
elle est un petit peu mécontente quand
même elle est un petit peu mécontente
quand même elle avait elle a sa date de
concert en même temps que Beyoncé donc
forcément elle se fait un petit peu
effacer par Beyoncé correspond 20 stades
de France au nombre de demandes qui a eu
apparemment parce qu'il faut rappeler
qu'elle a fait ça fait 4,5 ans qu'elle a
pas fait de concert et que là elle
revient mon ami merci exprès de faire un
concert moins long que celui de Lyon
pour pouvoir se rendre c'est à dire non
c'est pas d'ironie elle adore donc ça
les fans
bien sûr cavalier elle adore Beyoncé au
contraire elle a déjà invité ses fans
elle a dit à Beyoncé elle interpellé
Jean sur Twitter en lui disant tu as
intérêt à faire un concert de 4h comme
tu sais si bien le faire le mec dura 2h
par un mec parce qu'on a tous se
précipiter après au Stade de France
[Musique]
la pause c'est cette photo elle s'est
fait massacrée sur les réseaux parce
qu'on a dit c'est ça la plus belle femme
du monde elle a ici là on va mal c'est
pixelisé mais ici elle a des petites
vergetures
donc il y a marqué eh les gars la plus
belle femme du monde c'est pas elle
désolé il y en a beaucoup plus jolie
sans vergetures et ben vieillir c'est
vraiment bien et encore elle a du
maquillage elle a répondu en 2023 il y a
encore des gens choqué par des
vergetures j'ai toujours eu ces
vergetures ça n'a jamais empêché les
gens de me trouver belle le problème sur
les réseaux sociaux je trouve que en
général les ce sont les femmes qui se
bastonnent entre elles mais souvent
souvent c'est des réflexions de meufs
envers des nanas
et je trouve que c'est triste justement
qui est pas cette espèce de sororité à
un moment donné faut un tout petit peu
serrer les coudes entre nous parce qu'on
a déjà un monde dans lequel on vit qui
est un petit peu compliqué et je trouve
que entre femmes le jour où ça cessera
ce genre de de commentaire mais vraiment
fileux le monde ira beaucoup mieux
retire son mandat de la famille Kress
donc voilà la série l'agence cartonne en
ce moment c'est une sorte de série télé
sur la famille Crète on a de la chance
on voit des lieux que personne ne voit
on ouvre des portes que personne d'autre
déjà je vous dis juste que maintenant
l'estimation sera aux alentours de 10
millions et demi d'euros là la retirer
parce qu'elle pense que vraiment c'est
pas bien pour elle de passer par les
médias c'est quoi l'histoire qu'est-ce
qu'on a fait cette maison elle a détruit
en fait elle a fait une grosse bêtise
elle a continué ce qui était déjà le cas
c'est-à-dire à la contribuer à la
pipoliser à médiatiser une maison qui a
pas besoin de l'être et en gros la
plupart des gens qui se renseignent ils
ont pas envie parce qu'ils vont savoir
les gens vont savoir qu'ils sont combien
ils ont payé sont dans cette maison donc
ça c'est la première chose donc elle a
elle est passée maintenant elle a donné
pas l'exclus mais il y a plusieurs
agences plus de deux il y en a trois ou
quatre qui peuvent vendre cette maison
et qui a un énorme problème qui a pas
encore été dit tous les les potentiels
clients qui vont en ressort déçu parce
qu'elle n'a que des petites pièces il y
a deux autres problèmes aussi avec la
maison de Johnny Hallyday je pense c'est
que les gens qui ont vraiment de
l'argent par exemple les Saoudiens les
Russes ils en ont rien à [__]
d'acheter la maison de Johnny Hallyday
ça c'est une certitude et le deuxième
problème c'est qu'effectivement comme le
disait Florian la maison elle a besoin
d'être un petit peu homstage c'est à
dire qu'elle est restée dans une espèce
de forme de mausolée de Johnny Hallyday
les gens qui ont vraiment vraiment du
pognon d'ailleurs ce genre de somme
c'est des gens qui viennent avec des
énergéticiens des maîtres Feng Shui etc
vous avez vraiment envie d'aller dans
une maison où il y a eu des dettes des
disputes
tous les gens qui l'ont vu on dit la
même chose c'est banvise voilà